[Musique]
bonjour je suis Mélissa Sebire la
fondatrice de la mode de Mélissa et je
vous retrouve aujourd'hui pour vous
donner quelques astuces pour vous aider
à savoir si un vêtement vous convient
vraiment ou pas l'idée dans cette
chronique c'est de vous partager deux
astuces on va dire ça comme ça deux
points de vue en tout cas la forme et la
couleur et je vais commencer avec vous
par la couleur j'ai tendance à dire que
ça n'est pas vous qui choisissez le
vêtement mais c'est lui qui vous choisit
en fait il y a une astuce toute simple
pour savoir si une couleur vous va bien
ou pas il suffit de poser le vêtement
sous votre menton et en fait vous allez
voir tout de suite si votre visage
s'illumine vous voyez quand je mets du
rose parce que je sais que le rose est
une couleur qui qui illumine un petit
peu mon visage normalement vous voyez
déjà une différence
et si je viens mettre une chemise bleue
un peu plus foncée donc bleu marine on
voit bien qu'il y a pas le même éclat
qu'avec le rose voilà c'est comme ça que
vous allez savoir si votre vêtement vous
convient réellement ou pas
[Musique]
quand on parle de mode on parle souvent
de silhouette de morphologie en ah y
voilà plein de lettres comme ça et en
fait ces idées là vous dirigent vers des
clichés pour choisir vos vêtements mais
je suis pas forcément d'accord avec ça
parce que pour moi on doit s'habiller
comme on a envie de s'habiller et c'est
pas parce qu'on est un ovale un 8 ou peu
importe qu'on ne peut pas porter de
vêtements amples ou au contraire qu'on
ne peut pas porter de vêtements serrés
près du corps c'est vraiment quelque
chose que je ne défends pas c'est
silhouettes parce que justement la mode
doit être vecteur de de gaieté etc et
doit refléter votre personnalité ça
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut vraiment
pas oublier donc ne suivez pas tous les
conseils qu'on peut trouver sur les
morphologies vous devez cacher vos bras
à 50 ans vous devez plus mettre de jupe
et tout non non non non non
habillez-vous comme vous en avez envie
et un conseil que je peux tout vous
donner c'est la robe portefeuille
donc la robe portefeuille c'est vraiment
une pièce qui va à toutes les
morphologies et qui va à toutes les
femmes ça je peux vous l'assurer c'est
parfait pour pour tout le monde si vous
avez un peu de poitrine le décolleté en
V va la mettre en valeur et si vous avez
beaucoup de poitrine ça va sublimer
juste ce qu'il faut sublimer si jamais
le décolleté vous dérange vous rajoutez
un caraco en dessous vraiment il y a
toujours des petits tips pour faire en
sorte que le vêtement vous convienne et
que vous soyez aussi confortable et à
l'aise dedans et en fait le fait d'avoir
une ceinture autour de la taille va vous
créer une silhouette et donc que vous en
ayez ou pas que vous soyez en H ou en X
vous pouvez porter ce type de robe et
après le côté portefeuille de la jupe va
voilà apporter de la légèreté va
dévoiler sans trop dévoiler vos jambes
et de ce fait ça convient à toutes les
femmes et pour conclure ce petit épisode
je voudrais juste vous demander de vous
assumer et de libérer votre créativité
au travers de vos vêtements vous êtes
très belle comme vous êtes
et montrez le
[Musique]